[Music]
so there's actually uh an indian couple
living in a region that experienced
severe flooding
so they ended up taking an unusual
vehicle to reach their wedding venue a
cooking pop they [ __ ] floated there
they floated there a guy named akash
kunjuman said he and his wife aishwarya
i hope i didn't butcher that were
legally married october 6 but their
wedding ceremony was planned for october
18th and there was a flat kunjuman said
the ceremony was originally to have been
held at a temple but recent floods
caused the religious building to be
filled with water so the event was moved
to a nearby hall with a stage that had
not been submerged
although we tried to arrange a small
boat to reach the venue none was
available so he said officials at the
temple provided an alternative solution
and people from the temple arranged the
pot for us so how big is this pot dude i
hope it's really small wow that's cool
oh that's a cooking pot dude
[Music]
that's pretty tight though that's pretty
baller did they use that talent
other people
that's just huge
right yo that's dope
he has good friends got it okay
guys
that's resourceful that's gonna get to
the wedding you know what i mean it
always trips me out like how physics
work you know when you're like you got
two humans right that's gotta be at
least like 300 pounds plus the pot but
just because of the way the pots shaped
they can stay above water no right dude
when you look at some of these
battleships i'm like how is this even
possible yeah i'm like how's it just
sitting there in the harbor like that
what the [ __ ] and it's all metal like
damn that is crazy and then like how
much of it is actually submerged for it
to be held like that and stuff like that
because even if you take a quarter right
you're like i'm put on its sides it's
nice and flat it'll disperse and you
just put it and just [ __ ] goes down
that's just density right it's not this
because there's no hollow element to it
i don't know the [ __ ] physics behind
it yeah dude i just respect physics but
i don't know [ __ ] about it
he gets mad at you
get the [ __ ] out of here newton's the
thing i think dude magnet have you guys
seen magnet
trains oh [ __ ] it like bullet chains
like bullet chains right but they but
they like hover oh because the little
friction floating it's frictionless yeah
floating bro that's that's what gives
them the speed because usually um the
weight of it and the friction is the
thing that causes it to like constantly
need where do they have these japan all
the way a lot of countries have them now
but yeah
i knew that japan was the first one
we're supposed to have one uh that goes
to san francisco any time that was
supposed to be a magnitude i mean we all
probably voted on it like we were in
high school they're not
i think they spent billions of dollars
on and then like nah never mind and then
i'm sure you know i'm sure we'll get
that money back uh i'm sure it wasn't
that happens a lot in america what's the
hyperlink no that wasn't that the one
that goes vegas yeah hyperloop goes to
vegas so that's new new that's not done
yet no that's not even uh magnets that
one is there's just zero moving parts
so even it's like a pill that gets
thrown yeah because i think
there's no there's no air yeah it's a
vacuum oh
like when you go to the bank and you
[ __ ] put a tube and it goes home yeah
yeah so the bullet train it's
frictionless on the bottom because of
the magnets but uh there's still um wind
factor because it's going through air
got it and there's a electric being
connected to the top so there's still
moving parts the hyper loop has no
moving parts and it goes through a
vacuum what is that gonna be done
there's someone in l.a going
like that so that's bringing you in as
long as they don't breathe it in yeah
because they're gonna get the whole
train down like
once they say it's done
l.a to vegas in 30 minutes dude are you
gonna take that [ __ ] yeah for sure the
[ __ ] yeah i think the station's at
resorts world yeah because that resorts
world i saw it set the vegas loop right
they're already building this is it
gonna be done so the bull train is the
magnet thing yeah bullet journal what
the freak technically like old now with
with the onset of the hyperloop wow
because virgin's making one elon musk is
making one i was competing i thought
elon was making it and then virgin
picked up the project to go to vegas
really i don't know i think they're
guess what that's gonna do to property
values in vegas you know what i'm saying
yeah
investing early it really will be people
will probably be living there working
here exactly damn like new jersey new
york when's that gonna be like
a like legit we gotta figure this out
because i think they've been remember
the latest san francisco one and i was
hella sad when i found out i wasn't
gonna yeah because they just [ __ ]
burned all the money like they always do
they did the same [ __ ] in hawaii they
have a they had a train system that they
spent like
11 billion or whatever still not
finished there's no corruption though
okay virgin hyperloop and hyperloop
transportation technologies are working
to bring hyperloop into a reality by
2030. [ __ ] me
[ __ ] out of here dude hey you just got
to hold on to your house for that 30.
yeah i'd be dead i feel like it's fast
but i also feel like by the time we get
to 2030 especially with the exponential
like it's like eight years oh yeah
something else is gonna be way sicker
it's gonna be outdated by then cold
fusion by then bro we'll have
teleportation by then black holes
i love that watching this indian couple
float across their wedding in a pot talk
we're straight to bullet trains and
hyperloop dude like that's the sickest
[ __ ] same [ __ ] i still think that's dope
like that's dope ass like homies to do
that to just figure out a problem solve
and bring a big ass pot over and push it
back well first off who owns a pot that
big yeah absolutely that's not good
it's not like a it's not a regular
consumer
that's like everybody needs to
contribute all their [ __ ] hunter
gatherer [ __ ] for the day in order for
everyone does it fit on my stove yeah
this is huge they don't do stuff like
that it's like a bonfire that's like
yeah or light a shack on fire and put
the pot over i like watching this um
indian
cooking channel it's called like my food
my something or whatever right but this
dude will have big ass pots like that or
big ass things right and then he will
cook for the whole entire village so his
whole process is you see like
200 chickens or whatever you see a whole
[ __ ] ton of food just being made
and then the whole like everyone comes
down and they get some tandoori chicken
or whatever even the dog gets a piece
dude and i was like damn this is like
next level cooking i enjoy really large
family feasts i love it well nothing's
about a giant pot and just like
everybody go into it on like a campsite
or something
but uh they said they they traveled in
that pot for at least 20 minutes to get
to the venue damn if it's hyperloop it
would have been past the statement
they didn't get a hyperloop over there
it was too slow i was watching this uh
video the other day about how um
planes uh like commercial jetliners and
stuff and planes in like the 80s were
actually um
getting to this point where they're way
faster than the commercial planes that
we actually use now to travel way faster
what'd they change all right they
de-function one of them with the [ __ ]
plane that looks like this concord yeah
the concourse that was supersonic yeah
wait what would they change yeah so the
problem was um one they were supersonic
and anything that goes supersonic meant
that anything that those things were
flying over would create like sonic
reverberations that would like shatter
ah
just it'll fly by other planes and other
players be like ah [ __ ] and then the
glasses break
the plane spins around
from a supersonic level that was already
crazy and then from a cost efficiency
and jet um or like an engine fuel uh
position like that that means that
people in today's world would have to
pay like so much money in order to
travel so to get quantity they like
slowed down the actual like
technological advancements and stuff but
imagine if everybody's [ __ ] flying
super sonic all the time pretty
fascinating actually yeah that's
probably why the pilots are so lazy now
because they're like i used to [ __ ]
go in like fifth gear they want me to
cruise in like third gears [ __ ]
boring and we just get a [ __ ] from
the other pilot yeah yeah that's a real
thing right is that i'm i'm thinking
southwest
i
this is the second time in the past two
days i've heard someone reference the
fact that two pilots when they're the
cockpit suck each other off where does
that come from it's called cockpit
obviously but like is that a thing that
people usually because you get bored for
10 hours just sitting there the machine
does all the work wait are there like
actual never they're like these articles
that come out about this test some [ __ ]
not yet wait isn't it why is it okay why
is that a thing have you ever talked
about it have you seen pilots look at
each other they gave each other the look
they do give each other
when they close the cockpit door it's
always both of them looking at you yeah
while they close and go
you know what we're going to do
so that's a real thing and then the hot
ass flight attendant is like let me in
let me in
do you guys know there's no voice club
they're definitely not virgin airlines
no yeah no [ __ ] way i google do
co-pilots have sex in the cockpit and
the first thing i popped up from daily
mail says what really goes on inside the
cockpit pilots lift the lid on their
secret activities and claim crew members
do have sex on the plane pilots have
lifted the lid on the shocking
activities they get up in the coffin
including playing chess and challenging
each other to make dangerous landings
what the [ __ ] that's lit oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] crazy
uh the captain was like doing this whole
ad about getting a new credit card and
then and then there was a loud bang
we were landing the craziest turbulence
i've ever experienced in my life and
then the cockpit started filling up with
smoke
and the honolulu [ __ ] uh fire
department had to come in in the
airplane in the airplane dude so like
you saw steam coming out of the smoke
coming in the loud bang
turbulence must've been good head and
dude these guys were sucking each other
off bro but this guy i think most of the
reason why the we had a rough landing
was because the [ __ ] pilot was trying
to sell this goddamn credit card he
wasn't even paying attention he was like
a 15-minute ad i was like all right bro
and they always interrupt your [ __ ] when
it's ending [ __ ] movie yeah
and my yeah i had to stop watching my
[ __ ] jason state the movie i don't
know what happened at the end can i get
the card and then you never do this to
me again get the [ __ ] out of here
imagine what they do in space like if
you're gone that long dude they're
pegging each other and they're like if
you're like the first person to ever
have sex i definitely fantasize about
like zero gravity come just floating in
the videos oh yeah
just this
when they're coming back from the space
launch because they just they you know
they do all these like huge space
launches now when they're coming back
they're doing the credit card for the
last 45 minutes
to the three crew members
yeah i wonder how sex would be different
without gravity that'd probably be
really hard
would it be easier or harder to thrust
harder probably because it's
frictionless right yeah you hit somebody
they just fly [ __ ] you know yeah you
go bye and then she flies off your dick
and yeah i was listening to this
astronaut
tell the story where he's like working
out since there is no gravity it's
really hard yeah he was saying the the
thing that you never experienced is your
sweat dripping back upwards too
so you can train right and like let's
say you just kind of shake it off your
sweat will fly off and start going to
your neighbor oh damn hell is skin
flakes too when you're scratching it's
just a different environment you can't
even you're [ __ ] working out and then
this wiggles into your eyes
yeah you're just taking this [ __ ] and
just goes back up your back
oh because you could be like right side
up right but then the spaceship could be
upside down and you don't even know how
come they don't have like gravity
control up in that [ __ ] they do they do
that's what well again i'm just [ __ ]
watching movies so i'm going to shut up
on this but don't they do like uh
rotations and stuff like that what
they're doing the iss that's so that's
how they create natural gravity up there
you [ __ ] idiot
[ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
you